next Harry Katz former head curator of
the division of print and photographs at
the Library of Congress with a
collection of photographs illustrations
and newspaper clippings that provided
the inspiration for Mark Twain's writing
this is a little under an hour
a little microphone adjustment
understandable I'm I'm really really
happy to be here today because this is a
culmination of about three years of
really really wonderful work with my my
author Harry Katz
I want to talk a little bit about what
we're going to do today usually when we
do a slide show with these kind of
presentations
we're timing the talk or we're talking
directly to the slides and the content
of the slides there's so many good
slides today Harry and I decided to do
something a little bit different we're
going to use the slides this kind of
wallpaper we're going to run a slide
show there's going to be presumably yes
it's up we're going to run 30 seconds
for each slide there's about 70 slides
we may be referencing the slides
occasionally but we will be talking
about the book in general and as you see
the slides and if you have any questions
about the individual slides feel free to
ask us at the end of the presentation so
without further ado I'm going to
introduce Harry Katz who's our author
today Harry's former head curator in the
division of prints and photographs in
the Library of Congress and his books
include civil war sketchbook and two
great books with the publishing office
baseball Americana and her blog so
without further ado here's Harry Katz
okay how's the sound good thank you all
for coming and so it's a wonderful for
me to be back here with so many
wonderful friends and former colleagues
that I recommend recognizing the
audience it's a pleasure to be here and
I'm excited about this book we arguing a
little differently this this was a
mammoth ambitious project to pull all
this material together I could not have
done it alone and I didn't do it alone
I had publishing office support prints
and photographs division was always and
it has great professional staff
wonderful images putting everything
online that they can so for me starting
with this book this is this was as as
Tom said this is I've done now a few
books since since I've been with the
library and the inspiration for Twain
there were two parts of that I was in in
2000 2010 late 2009 I was working on
there on a book about civil war sketch
artist and I'm talked to a friend who
said well what are you going to do next
and I'm like I had just got to finish
this and he says well you got it you got
to do how about Mark Twain she lives in
Redding Connecticut which is where he
died the writing library's there she has
a son who basically every day on
Facebook and I'm on Facebook with him
he'd be quoting Twain and in that time
period that was when the the first
volume of the unexpurgated autobiography
came out and so it's the digital age and
people I'm riding the riding Subway's
night and people are carrying around the
six eight pound book and it's 2010 and
it's they're reading Mark Twain's
autobiography it's huge
thick and they're reading it they're
carrying it with and I said well well I
can't do Mark Twain
yes I sort of stro how do i do mark lane
well I worked with pictures and and when
I began looking at what the library had
and what might be possible with Twain in
a picture book that's when I had that
epiphany that yes I can do this but I
have to do it my own way with pictures
and I have to do it my own way with text
and that's sort of when it took up and
then the next thing we knew that summer
2010 the the the the book lent is sort
of viral read the Autobiography it was
number two on Amazon it was behind Harry
Potter and it's like Harry Potter and
Mark Twain okay but the thing is if you
look online if you look on television if
you look anywhere there is so much Twain
out there Twain has become a sort of a
cultural lightning rod we all have our
own Mark Twain and people all over the
world have their Mark Twain we're
reading Mark Twain elsewhere because of
its criticisms an American Society
they're reading about politics in places
of races and all these things that are
important around the world and Twain is
part of that conversation and that was
that was what was the spark for me is
there's an old guy sitting on a porch
reading and that's our Mark Twain and
yet Twain is everywhere and so his life
has really I think it we are we are now
at this time where we can fully
appreciate who he was and what he did
and that's I needed to find out for
myself
because I've read Twain all my life but
I didn't really understand what was
going on until I did this book I want I
wanted Tom to be up here with me because
as I say this was a team effort
you know the first thing I guess I'm
going to do this book on Twain the
second thing is I said was how am I
going to do is click on Twain I'm going
to have to read for the rest of my life
and to a certain extent is true you get
more familiar with
Twain the more you look the more you
read you know all the novels all the
sketches the correspondence I mean words
words words thousands ten thousands
hundreds millions of words that you have
to read to understand Twain but pictures
go beyond them because you can see
immediately what's happening they're
visceral in a way that words aren't and
for me words carry meaning they're real
that just they're just as real as any
letter any document in a lot of cases
they're more real because you're you can
you can manipulate in writing it's it's
actually harder to manipulate an image
once it's taken than it is to just
manipulate what you're writing so for me
the exercise is to make sure that every
image in this book is not only what it
was it's represented at what it
represents but that it's real it's a
real photograph from this period there
aren't reproductions there are you know
looking back a hundred years back these
are all period pieces from the Library
of Congress and these are these are
artifacts just as strong just as true as
any document so this was our coach to
take this man and in words and pictures
cut back the layers of history the
layers of interpretation the layers of
our understanding back till hundred
years ago
throughout his life when we can really
see who it was in what what he was doing
now there aren't many Twain authors who
have sort of they've had to come to
grips with Twain himself because you're
you're dealing not you're not dealing
with one person you're dealing with
Clemens you're dealing with Twain you're
dealing with a man
is sort of outside his time and yet
firmly embedded in it at the same time
he's an avatar he is almost this you
know this literary God who understands
the world he's been everywhere he
traveled everywhere he worked everywhere
he met kings and queens and royalty in
Europe he was in the mines in Nevada he
was among the literati in New York it's
the same guy but there's there's so many
angles and so many parts of Twain that I
certainly needed help to just assemble
his life and just to go over the course
of his life so I'd like Tom to actually
talk a little bit about how we laid out
the book because that was very important
I spent so much time right time writing
about Twain and then getting to that
point where tom was here you know you
don't you're not writing another
biography of Twain you're writing a
biography of the country that embraced
Twain we're writing about our love for
this man and what he did which began you
know long before he was dead so there's
this long history of just reverence for
claim and we wanted to to to explore
that in a way in one volume where you
could see the whole picture and we
really started out not knowing I
understood that there would be images
that we would see and there would be
wonderful things but we really didn't
know what write I think what we tried to
do in organizing the book was to have a
kind of chronology of Twain's life
running through the book but to pick at
certain times of Twain's life Twain was
fascinated with certain subjects or was
becoming a certain kind of personality
so the five chapters of the book are
called river of dreams
that's about his fascination with the
river that everybody knows about from
Tom Sawyer and Huckleberry Finn life on
the Mississippi and his youth in animal
the second chapter was called true West
and it was about Western Swing excuse me
Western Swing true West was a working
title and that was about that was about
Twain's sojourn in the West which
basically got him out of serving in the
Civil War and also where he made his
bones as a writer he was a he was a flop
as a prospector he was very bad as a
prospector but he found his voice as a
writer which he had already started
finding when he was back in Missouri and
then the third chapter is called
trademark and that's when Mark Twain
comes back to New York from the West and
he decides to make his living as a
writer and not just be a writer but
actually to be a public personality in a
way Mark Twain was probably the first
American writer maybe even the first
American famous person to understand the
idea of branding yourself so that takes
us through the 70s and the 80s and then
we get to a point where Mark Twain
becomes bigger than just a writer
he becomes an American Oracle that's our
fourth chapter he becomes the kind of
guy who's a go-to person for quotes not
just from his writing but also from his
speaking because he becomes a very
famous public speaker and an incredible
performer as a live performer so that
was the fourth chapter and then the
fifth chapter we kind of circled back to
talking about Mark Twain's circle the
family that nourished him that he grew
up in that he created with his wife Livy
the people he worked with and for the
rivals and the colleagues that he had
over the years and finally at the end of
his life a very constricting and
different kind of circle of friends and
relatives and acquaintances so that's
the way we organized the book yeah and
the tough thing is you I think the way
we found it was really ingenious it was
Tom and Ralph Eubanks our former
publishing head now of Virginia
quarterly who really helped me
understand because this was a very
difficult process I'm looking I have to
look at pictures I have to look at his
writings I have to look at his life
mark claimed did more in one year than
most people did in a lifetime if you
look at his travel itinerary and there
you can find all these all these
wonderful maps and graphs and things but
he went everywhere I mean you look at
the course of his life there was no
nobody had travelled more and wrote more
and seen more and throughout his
writings it's about what he's seeing and
what he's observing and and this
increasing sophistication of this writer
who then has a thumb on the pulse of of
the nation and really rides this wave of
incredible popularity and so one of the
first images I remember thinking about
this book was actually from the ulta I
think life on the Mississippi where
they're under the two kids on the river
bamb ition where they talk about the
ambition to be a steamboatman which
which plane talks about quite frequently
every but all the kids in Hannibal want
it to be
steamboat pilots or steamboat workers
and and so that image of this young boy
on the edge of it really on the edge of
civilization all the wilderness by a big
river and how that river and all the
things that it carried the people that
the cargo the the steamboat men
themselves all these things that enliven
planes early imagination and early life
but it's that that image of him by the
big river sort of money outside of this
growing civilization and then in by 1910
when he passes he's living in an
Italianate villa outside you know
outside New York City it's just how do
you get from this structure little
uneducated belligerent kind of wayward
youth to one of the most magnificent
commentators the most brilliant minds
we've ever seen
that's the journey that was the journey
for me to take him from that riverbank
to really the capital the world and the
height of sophistication of civilization
and by doing what we did we essentially
for each chapter we carried the theme
forward so for the the first chapter
which is the the river of dreams chapter
we carry that theme of the river all the
way through that chapter because he goes
back to the river
he leaves Hannibal at about 1851 does
some traveling east to the East Coast
cities doing journey man printing comes
back to Hannibal then goes then ends up
with it becomes a steamboat pilot then
with the onset of the Civil War he goes
west but we carry the river right
through his life he was the last time he
was in Hannibal was 1902 where he caught
up alone all of his old friends that
were had been basically the the models
for the people in Huckleberry Finn so
there's this always this sort of return
to Hannibal return to the river return
to his roots but he never lives there he
never goes back to the south to live and
in his writing the self becomes another
land in a way a land that with so much
potential but sort of burdened by
history and burdened by a cent a feudal
Sensibility almost the historical
sensibility that keeps that keeps the
self from advancing into the 20th
century he he taught writes about at
length about those things when he goes
west into the mining camps his whole
world
the trip as described in roughing it as
I mean reading it it's just absolutely
hysterical
he and his brother get on a stagecoach
and go west the brothers is going to be
the secretary of the territory of Nevada
which had just just been opened it was
really nothing there except for some
mining communities and that's where they
went and that's where Twain found you
know not my gold but a lifetime of
creativity in writing that's where he
sort of launched himself into the world
of writing professionally you want to
talk a little bit about so again with
chapter 2 we talk about the west and
follow it through in chapter 3 we talk
about his his creativity his developing
a professional persona do you want to
talk a little bit about yeah I think
what the interesting thing about Twain
is he kind of yo-yoed around the country
for a long time trying to kind of find
himself and find his voice and find out
what he really wanted to do when he grew
up in some ways 20 never grew up that
was one of the charms about him I think
that's what attract a lot of people to
him but when Twain came back from the
West and Canton arrived in New York in
1867 New York was the place to be even
then it was the place to be especially
as a writer and what Twain understood
was that not only were a lot of writers
there a lot of artists were there a lot
of interesting culture was going on
there was even public personalities like
Henry Ward Beecher who was then
America's most famous preacher and Twain
made a point of going to his church and
checking out Beecher but also kind of to
be seen Twain had this ambition that if
he was going to be a public personality
he had to be seen he had to be seen in
the right places so he did lectures as
you know he was probably America's
greatest lecturer at a time when
lectures were really a great public
entertainment this is pre electronic
media people went to live lectures all
the time and Mark Twain was one of the
best he was funny he was provocative he
was witty he was very personable and
people love to hear Bart Winston is
sailes so Mark Twain made himself into a
public personality in the epicenter of
where the public would glom on him and
know him and his first big break as a
writer came when he discovered that
Beecher was taking a group of pilgrims
across the Atlantic Ocean to the Holy
Land and was actually the first real
formal Cruise in American history it was
it was kind of a pleasure cruise but it
was also a an educational cruise we've
all heard about those some of us have
been on those they killed them pilgrims
so it was it was for moaning a
pilgrimage by boat and so the first
public yeah cruise and Twain decided
this is a great subject for something to
write about he didn't go on the cruise
because he himself was that religious he
was religious but he was also a
religious skeptic if you if you might or
skeptical devout person but at any rate
he decided to go on the cruise and kind
of check things out and he decided to
write about the cruise as it was
happening and made notes met a lot of
people on the ship got to be friends
with a lot of people including his
future brother-in-law they arrived in
the Holy Land they went to other sites
in Europe he wrote up all these notes
sent them back to a newspaper in
California they started publishing these
stories and they were a big sensation
and he went wait a minute
like any good writer I can turn this
into a book and so that's what he did
and that's innocence abroad and that
really really launched his career as a
writer of books and those books were
distributed in a different way he worked
for American publishing company which
was a subscription book service and
subscription books were sold
door-to-door like Bibles encyclopedias
or vacuum cleaners it was a different
setup than many of the the old line
publishers who would do it more you know
you basically need a community
and and a distribution network but with
bliss with the publishers of American
publishing company it was very popular
you're getting to people who don't
always read and don't always read books
and one of the reasons I think that is
is because their visual because these
books have pictures they have pictures
of Twain himself those pictures are a
'td you know illustrations from the text
which are by many of the best
illustrators of the era either true
Williams or Campbell in the case of Huck
Finn he not only were there images from
the book but they're images of Twain so
he became known the other thing is these
books were not meant to be read they
were meant to be read aloud the whole
nature the whole notion of how families
got together they would get together in
the parlor and read to each other and
the mother the father maybe the kids but
so you can you imagine you know some of
the passages if you're reading innocents
abroad or roughing it you're just saying
my goodness this is a high Victorian age
they're sitting in the stuffy old Tyler
and they're reading these amazing
sentences with vulgarity humor sacrilege
all the wonderful things that you
wouldn't want your kid to learn you're
actually now reading it out loud to your
kids so it's very subversive in that way
and it's subversive in a I think a
visual way which appeals to me because
the the illustrations not only take what
was only becoming a literary country
they really before the 1840s 1850s is
very little in the way of Education as
Twain talked about and so I think you
know later when his books came out there
was enough of an audience that could
read could be read to and just look at
the pictures too
you know even if you can't get every
word or understand everything you can
see what's happening and I think that's
a big difference for Twain not only in
branding himself but
using illustrations to bring in as many
readers as possible right and I think
then what you would the interesting
jumping-off point from innocence abroad
is you know what do you do to follow up
a big bestseller and it was a huge
bestseller so Twain did roughing it
which which which did well but but then
his next book was what I would call kind
of the most current novel he wrote which
is called the Gilded Age and one of the
things that was okhla rant about it was
the title was something that he and his
co-author Charles Dudley Warner thought
up to describe an era in which people
were more interested in making money
than anything else they weren't
interested in helping their fellow man
they were just interested in making
money if this sounds familiar
they'll just just go right on and and
think your own thoughts about it I won't
draw any conclusions but the Gilded Age
was a great satire about Washington and
Washington politics and Washington
lobbyists and Washington lawyers and
Washington dreamers and schemers and
there was even a character named
Washington in it and we actually for
$10,000 you could have a senator for
another 10,000 you could get a really
terrific female lobbyists to lobby that
Senator so you know I mean there's so
much about trying to go back and to look
at politics and the Gilded Age he named
the they named the year before it
happened it was written in 1873 that's
the start of the Gilded Age in so many
ways Twain was it ahead of his time or
as I said before almost outside of his
time because he saw these things he
because he I believe because he was an
outsider he had an incredibly fertile
brain incredibly sensitive personality
he was kind of sickly when he was born
and I think there was something in him
spiritually emotionally intellectually
that really connected with life
connected with people and and that's
thing that I found it was quite
extraordinary about him then the the
dent way makes another kind of left turn
in his in his career and he kind of goes
backwards first of all he he's asked by
William Dean Howells it was one of the
leading editors of the day and with whom
he become friends to write a book about
his his youth and the Mississippi Twain
would spin these tales talk to his
friends about life growing up in
hannibal and what it was like in the pre
Civil War days and so he wrote a series
of articles for for house and and these
these kind of stirred up something
inside of him he realized that he had a
lot of kind of unresolved you might say
issues with his upbringing not that he
was resentful but that he was still
processing what it was like it was very
very different before the civil war in
this South in some ways because of the
steamboat trade especially but also
there was a different atmosphere and so
he decided to kind of mind that but he
minded in a very accessible approachable
popular way which was The Adventures of
Tom Sawyer kind of an autobiographical
novel about some of the kids that he
knew growing up and some of the adults
who were making their lives miserable
and he came up with this brilliant idea
to just kind of capsulate this this
pre-war south Mississippi River kind of
society and it was a huge huge seller he
wrote inevitably had to write a sequel
to it it was it was not only inevitable
financially but it was also inevitable
emotionally for him to go and take that
material and then turn it turn it on not
on it's upside down but turn it in such
a way that it became a lot darker and a
lot more I would say interesting and
that's what Finn yeah well Huck Finn I
mean is another long step beyond Tom
Sawyer in terms of social social
commentary that stands alone really in
terms of this is 1880
a 485 and you're talking again about a
country and reconstruction rebuilding at
a time when the really the generation of
the war is turning over again and this
the country is taking taking a look back
and what plane is doing is you see sort
of stripping the world of its illusions
and he you know basically when your
illusions are gone what do you have left
well a lot of his illusions fell away
about the south about the country and
this book is very much part of my effort
to strip away those illusions to see
what plane was like to see him in his
era and the things that were around him
the things you know for example we're
looking at ralphie brothers black crook
that's a wonderful popular print from
prints and photographs division it Wayne
wrote numerous screenplay out I should
say play grips we're doing well there's
one movie of plains yeah let me a little
snippet of him but the idea is he was
very into drama and theater and he knew
had been booth he knew many of the
principal theatrical people he developed
as I say his own stage scripts and then
so you what we found are all these sort
of personal interests and Kansans
whether his dual identity and in Chang
Lee the the twin Siamese twins
there was always in his books this
duality it's a duality of good and evil
it's a duality of sort of
you basically you've got two people in
in one body and you've got Samuel
Clemens and Mark Lane you know two
people in one body this was an idea the
cat captured his imagination and has
shown throughout his writing so we're
trying to show those connections those
those what made plain different why do
we need another claim book
we need this book because it shows you
you know very in plain imagery what he
looked like I was his life went on and
what the country was doing at the time
why he was embraced why he became who he
was and we try to answer that and you
know this was again Mark Twain and
George Washington cable twins of genius
I was 1884 just when Huck Finn was
coming out they went on this
spectacularly successful tour of the
states and you know just like Twain and
cable for for me having Tom here was you
know we and that's a stranger we had we
we twin twins in New Jersey so you know
we need to be able to do half the work
and yeah that was my inspiration I'm not
sure what what times I did but but you
seen cleen's life in this context was
quite I think extraordinary because he
was so conscious of what he was doing
and he was so effective and again I
think now about Twain and his life and
the Twittersphere in the internet it's
pervasive and people all around the
world for one reason or another for
religion for politics for pets for race
for childhood for innocence for evil all
of these things he embeds into his books
because they were all things that he
thought about all the time and I hope in
the end what comes from this book is
that people will have
an idea that this is not mark playing on
Samuel Clemens and this and that it's
one person one fertile brain it's not
John Stewart or these folks today who
have a you know a crowd of writers
producing all this this is one man
working at his desk writing in ink we
forget that we have to go back to that
time and we have to see how it was on
how we begin our most legendary and
prolific writer I think what the
interesting kind of turning point in
Twain's personal life which I think
affected his writing a lot was his
moving to Europe in 1891 as you've seen
in some of the previous slides
he lived in a beautiful house in
Hartford if you ever get a chance to go
to this house believe me it's right up
there with Monticello is one of the
great American houses of a famous person
he built this house he and his wife
designed a custom and they lived there
with their daughters for about 17 years
for the expense of keeping up the house
of having all the family dropping in the
friends dropping in for for you know
just an overnight stay and of two weeks
later they're still there was a great
house who want to leave and you have
Mark Twain every night for dinner to
help spinning the story so who would
want to leave anyway and so the expense
of keeping up this house and also his
setbacks his personal setbacks of
finances forced him to move to Europe in
1891 it was actually cheaper to live in
Europe then than it was to live in
Hartford believe it or not so here's
what happened Twain lost physical touch
with America he still came back he still
came back to New York but it was a
different kind of writing that he was
doing he was he was more interested in
the the present-day he was commenting on
the present-day he was concerned about
things like the Trust's he was became
concerned in the eighteen not late 1890s
and early 1900s with imperialism he's
very much against some Teddy Roosevelt's
adventures abroad and considered
Roosevelt one of the worst presidents we
have ever had believe it
and he kind of changed in terms of the
kind of writing he was doing he would
still do a sustained novel from time to
time like Connecticut Yankee but it
wasn't the same energy and it wasn't the
same kind of attention to detail that he
had in his earlier writing and also the
writings weren't as popular
having said that Twain was still an
immensely influential and popular person
as a public personality yeah I just I
think we should probably finish up and
go on to some questions but I'd like you
know we're you see these creators I
think one of them his note claims most
prolific and happiest time was in the
1870s and 80s when they were living in
Hartford with his family and everything
seemed wonderful they would do
theatricals with his with his girls out
in the yard you know they did all these
wonderful wonderful things it was
incredibly productive time for him
professionally financially good really
well but again as Sam said life caught
up with him life caught up with his
decision-making there were a series of
ongoing tragedies within his family so
at the same time he's enjoying all this
incredible popular success his family is
starting to deteriorate and it becomes
very painful to watch and to see what
happens but for me that's just like
that's what we all go through and he's
not alone what he is unique in is the
way that he he made his own life
accessible he was the ultimate celebrity
he was the ultimate reality TV celebrity
because he opened his life up he opened
his family life his personal life his
professional life up to people they
would read about him all the time I mean
he was always in the newspapers always
in the news because he knew that this
was his that the people were his
audience the people were the though they
were the ones he wanted to spend time
then you see throughout his life mixing
with everybody from presidents to to
poppers and that that's really the way
he was and and so for me this is a story
of perseverance of resilience of
recreation reinvention he goes
everywhere in the world he could go and
he keeps reset he recycles old thing but
he creates new new interventions he's
very well-read in the sciences very
well-read in politics and it shows and
as a result we are left with this this
boy from the river who goes who goes on
to this career in the 1870s he goes to
Boston and roasts growth you know Oliver
Wendell Holmes and all of the great
Boston writers in the 1870s it was
dinner and he's just he does it's a
complete fiasco but at the end of his
life here he is he is one of those
literati
he's what he is now in the establishment
but to get there from Hannibal that's a
long way to get receded in this group of
William V house and all these amazing
writers to be considered at that group
to have a honorary degree from Oxford
have all the literary attention that was
shown to him and yet still at all he
never became he never lost the child
within him you never lost that kid who
was by the river who was open to
everything and completely transparent
and and I think that's really the
wonderful story about Twain is is who he
became and how consciously he worked to
become that man
okay thank you so we're we will open to
the floor to questions and he had a
question about a specific slide just let
us know we can try to get it back up on
the screen talk about it individually
hold on
you need to microphone okay toward the
end of his wife he wrote the mysterious
stranger and literary critics have
battened on that because they see it as
a revelation of how dark his vision of
the world had become almost a point of
Neil ISM and I was wondering have they
overdone that or do you think that
really did express his true utter
pessimism about life back toward the end
of his life yeah sure she asked the
question about the mysterious stranger
which is a late novel between wrote and
it was actually not even published in
his lifetime and it's a very very dark
story about a group of boys living in a
small village to encounter a the title
character mysterious stranger who turns
out to be pretty much the devil
incarnate and it's about the duality of
man's nature the dark of the light but
mostly about the dark well I you know
his life really took a turn in the 1890s
and and that going through bankruptcy
and then having to work back from that
losing his daughter Susie gene hit what
gene was ill Libby was always very
vulnerable always sick the 90s it became
a really difficult time and I think you
know this was his darkening path if you
go back earlier he did talk about
duality he did talk about God
God versus the devil Satan but it
becomes far more prevalent the clouds
gather they get darker and darker and
darker as you move from mid 90s up to
his death in 1910 he's going on rant he
is about anti-imperialism rants about
religion once against his Christian God
and it was his Christian God he was a he
was a a religious person who was
incredibly skeptical he said how could
our God create such a flawed thing as
man I mean and that's what he felt he
felt his flaws he saw his flaws and yet
he pushed forward he pushed through them
he kept moving and I think that is a big
lesson is that we are all flying we are
all human in a sense we're all damned
but you get up and you you push for
something new you because you're curious
you're engaged you will make mistakes
but those mistakes you know that's just
part of being human and so I think yes
the Braeden gotten much darker as that
went along and mysterious stranger who
was published after his death because it
was not something that the fan of
Huckleberry Finn would necessarily
countenance but there's a lot of
absolutely fantastic late critical
writing that he did it's dark but it's
human and very humane and that's where I
miss Riley bought MacLean is just how
human he was he saw himself as flawed he
saw himself as damned but you know he
said I'm going to do it anyway
any other questions right here hold on :
let's get the microphone to you okay I
have a question about Huckleberry Finn
in our lifetime there have been times
when it's been banned or certainly
labels is controversial during his
lifetime and was there any ever any
question about the morality or the
intention Huck Finn was an extremely it
was far more controversial than than
even it is now because that you know
that's I'm saying the books were sort of
to be read aloud you're bringing in all
this Twain Twain language Twain thinking
you know hell damn vulgarity race
relations he did it in a way that really
people you know there were in Concord
Massachusetts too but the book was
banned and and so in Massachusetts in
particular in other place it was just
beyond the pale that you'd sort of have
this writing in the in the youth market
in the family market and it was
extremely controversial nowadays yes
there are people who you know suggest
that the language the n-word is
something that doesn't belong you begin
to take things out of books and you just
change them completely you know there's
no question in my mind that the Twain he
grew up among slaves he grew up but but
his experience was so they were part of
this family they were part of his life
they were part of his world it took him
a while to sort of move to become more
worldly more aware of the true lives of
black people in America of Native
Americans you know when he was young he
had those young ideas he didn't see much
wrong with it but what immediately when
he came in tenth in a contact with Libby
family who was a
Northeast progressive family of
abolitionists emancipation you know he's
coming from the deep south and he
marries into that family and he wants to
be part of that family part of that team
and he begins to Amit's Frederick
Douglass he becomes much more aware
beyond personal what it is about race
that's the problem and that's true and
all he you can watch him growing up you
can watch his thoughts mature by all
these writings and by the end of his
life you know he's still ranting and
raving but in a lot of he's come a lot
of way a long way in terms of his
appreciation for you know a different
variety of American life he was a he was
a Democrat in the broadest possible
sense a Republican in the broadest sense
I think Lewis Lapham says in there he's
a most democratic writer and that's
absolutely true because he's writing
things foreign about you know our
democracy our fundamental way of life
which is about freedom it's about
independence and freedom and
independence so probably the two words
that Twain looked long for he longed for
the you know he talked about the
independent riverboat pilot who's the
king of all he surveyed and could not be
could not be crossed and so I think
there's a sense in him that as a writer
the commentator he had achieved that
kind of freedom and independence the
freedom and independence he never
achieved was freedom from his God which
drove him crazy because that
responsibility to God to religion was
something that there was a hook seven
him but he he just couldn't get rid of
and and I think that's where his
frustration came was because within the
realm of religion he wasn't free to do
whatever you want to and so I think
there's something in that yeah I would
say one thing about Huckleberry Finn
from my personal experience I was in
fourth grade our teacher read Tom Sawyer
aloud to us in class every afternoon for
about an hour
and we just loved it we ate it up this
would be about 1955-56 we all said we
know there's this other book that he
wrote about those same characters and
some other characters Huckleberry Finn
she said well I don't know I just it's
it's it's a harder book to read she kind
of walked whilst around it she didn't
want to read it to us and it was only
later when when we read it we understood
it was much more sophisticated it was a
lot darker and if you imagine people in
the 19th century being set up with Tom
Sawyer and oh here's his next book about
all those young scamp's on the river
let's read this in about three chapters
India you're going these aren't the
young scamp's I remember well they're
the same characters but it's definitely
a different point of view so I think
that was the thing that really sets
people off about Huckleberry Finn people
appreciated it certainly in its time but
I think they came to appreciate it even
more later on when they saw it in the
broad context of his career and also
that Mark Twain was a writer who evolved
he didn't just go back and do the same
book over and over again as we've seen
in this lecture one more question right
here
would you compare please that contrast
if that's the way it is the way in which
Twain is perceived in his homeland today
America with how he has perceived
elsewhere in the world well yeah the
question is how would we compare Twain's
reputation in America was his reputation
around the world the funny thing is you
know for all of his anti-imperialism
Twain was actually his books were sold
around the world through the English
trade market which was a quite quite an
imperial Empire a lot of the Huck Finn
was was published first in England the
the the Empire of Britain actually
embraced Twain before we did so there
was a strong European and even global
impulse toward plain
it was probably stronger in some areas
abroad than it was here but that very
after mark after Tom Sawyer and Huck
Finn he became one of our law you know
our most celebrated right there's no
other writer who can compare except that
after 1885 into the 90s when his message
became darker when his message became
more complicated and less pleasing oh
that's when maybe the book sales might
diminish but there was when he died
there was just this outpouring a level
of love people readers loved him for his
honesty
as much as his imagination so I think by
the nineties when one of the books and
the writing were getting darker there's
some diminishment in the popularity in
this country but it was overwhelmingly -
you know all over the world tributes
came in at his passing and there's no
question he was the most well traveled
well-loved writer but we've ever seen
and I think he's probably armed
pervasive writer on the Internet
speaking of book sales book sales and
signings are part of every books and
beyond and I invite you to purchase a
book at the library of congress discount
and have a chance to get a signed by
both authors and to have a small chat
with them about questions we haven't had
time to get answered but most of all I
really want to thank both both of our
both of our off well they're not our
typical presenters
both Harry and Tom Harry especially but
also Tom the work you've done in the
resources of the Library of Congress is
really remarkable I really went through
the book listening to you and you have
not only taken the Pinson photographs
collections but you know all of it and
your acknowledgments of all of the
really many many curators is really
remarkable and I want everyone to thank
you for the way that you've done the
Library of Congress proud it was a
wonderful presentation
recently Mark Twain scholars have
contended there are factual errors and
omitted sources in Mark Twain's America
in response to these accusations the
Library of Congress issued a statement
which reads the Library of Congress has
determined and regrets that our regular
and rigorous review processes were not
followed in the editing of the recent
publication Mark Twain's America we are
moving to correct resulting problems by
working with both the author and editor
to conduct a full cover to cover review
of the book any errors or omissions
discovered or otherwise brought to our
attention will be corrected in any
forthcoming editions